Yes it's running now. This is mr.
Jack crew recording at his home. And mr.
Jack drew you. You remember the days when
you worked for dorman long. What was your
job. First of all i was an office
boy i started in the office at
the age of fourteen and said i turned
sixteen. I know it's my time as
a boilermaker. Then after
the eno all the shops
closed and everybody finished. And
i got a job on the outside as
a signal boy. You know. And one
of the cranes on the pylon
and i was there for about six weeks
after they open. You were never
a painter on the bridge. No never fired
a. You when the crane was pulled
down. I was assisting the painters
. But never what was
a signal boy on the on the crane. If you
will the dog when he was down below.
Because the cry and i couldn't see him.
And i was about in the ledge. You know on
the south pylon and i had to relay
the signals from the document as
a kind of. That's when you weren't
using the telephone. No telephones
wasn't invented in those days.
Oh well actually they were but
it was more economical to have
somebody out on the ledge. Did they
ever relay whistle signals. It
wouldn't be able to hear them.
Well can you tell me what you did when
you first started as an office boy
a member of the office. Do you work there
live there didn't you. Yeah. The father
was
a caretaker on you know
in the office. And.
When i went down there. I had
better eleven years of age. But
you're not left school at
the age of fourteen. I got
a job in office given and the
message is doing to my oh
you're going up ahead of
us and peds. And all that.
And then when you went over to the
workshops. Oh i know that. Thomas ball
and whereabouts just out there what it
what we are doing when you went over there
first. The first couple of
months i was i was up in
the morning and
a temperate flow. And it went down below
into the actually into the workshop
. And the first six
months of the time it was
a billy boy. And all kinds of things.
Did you do any marking out there and
then what did you assembling or not as
assembly you don't. You didn't mark and
a lot of assembling you riveting. You know
and all that. Yes what do you remember
best about the workshops.
You've got to remember best
. You didn't have time to remember. The
very most because it was work and not like
it is today. You know but the
conditions of the workers. Pretty
bloody. You know in comparison
you working conditions today. Well
it was entirely different you know
dressing rooms no. Shower room.
You know anything like that.
I started of that i don't think the
work. I don't. Surely there were
a lot of money with. A dollar
a day isn't much now but it was i suppose
a bit in those days. How much was it. Oh
well it was a teenage shillings it was
a fair bit of money. You know comparison
to what they get the day because
conditions are entirely different you
know. And went to nueva and all that.
But they had to work. And
if you didn't work. All
they want to know why do you remember any
accidents or any tragic incidents in the
workshops or the bridge. I mean the
workshop. There was and. You one chap was
up on one of the kind and it was greasing
it. And some of these start at all. I
think that you caught in the
cogs. And i think for men.
We legs were. A cut of. About
. As apart from that. Well i can't
remember to remember out on the bridge
an accident there or any accident there.
The last chap that you fell off the bridge
. I think his name was campbell. It was out
on the needle. You know supporting the
ugandans for washing down the pilots
and you have that balance and
you fell onto the deck and
then you went through the
the rail i sleep you down at the bottom.
You know with
a well i did next election and but i
just you just seen what happened. I mean
did you know kelly another man who fell
off. Now i don't remember him because he
was
a it was up on the guard when i was in the
shop. But i believe you when they picked
him out of the water is. You know all
this close to or who any beaches that
you know where they break
open to the bottom. I did.
That wouldn't like to try to find out. Do
you remember any amusing things at the
workshop do you remember lunch hour or
anything around there then. Oh then the
lunch out there to have
a crown an anger board. Jarvis
and all that kind of carry on
. But you get the fantasies.
We used to sneak out the side
and go over the leaven to buy bars.
You know it's in the summertime.
And. And that was
a hole in the tin and you know as
a couple of times. The boss was white
and for us when we come back. He
give us
a play. Do you remember.
The methods of work in the workshops to
remember how how the steel came in and that
went through the workshop can you describe
it to you you. Well the steel used to
come in by ship. I mean given
you know they floated there
and you then conveyed enter
that. Into the marking of buys
it and you know all the steel was
coated boy or some kind of gluey stuff
. You know it was very hard to get over it
all at the beginning and you taken over
by hand and you we're yesterday.
They did and you get tagged along
a you dip it in an acid
bath. Or the sand glass it.
Much easier. You know what
makes you what do you
mean next. Well first of
all the steel. Yes to go up
to the marking of by you then
you go to drillers. Then they'd go to
the assembly. And after us all the
same but got a. What they called
a heavy shop and it will
be that it. And it go
onto a pontoon in
a dock as your floated out
for the arch. How do you
remember the you describe
what it was like in
a riveting game what exactly
went on. Bloody at work. Well
there was the river do
the hold up the cook.
As
a catcher. You know it
was in the gang and. You
when they had it. You know the hydraulically
that is you know it was an extra
couple to drag hoses and there was also
a gantry. And you know.
The big machine. Oh there was
a figure out you know but you
know millie in an ordinary with
a cane. It was the riveter the hold up as
a cook in the kitchen and what was
the process as it went through
everything. You covered with red led. You
know before it was assembled. I mean the
riveting process so how does it start. So
with the cook at it yet. Yes that's right
and they apply that to the kitchen.
And i'd put in the how and
how old i am but
a get under it and root of
the day the rest of the
the holder it was compressed
air too so what is he got
it's like
a riveting machine like an area bitter at
the back as well as the front as it will
actually as a holder have
a fixed machine. You know get
onto it and tighten it up and
. Then the river is on the other side. Was
there any difference in with the machine
that they hold up used on the rivet
abused. Oh no i don't think so. I would
like to riveting machines being away
together and unless you're into older you
got to do that in and they had
ended up with learned stop.
And all it do was wait until the river.
If you if you finished any dismantle. It
. Take it to rivet it gone to the next
one. Did you were never holding up. Of
course because europe. You were
a princess boilermaker so you only
actually did you did the riveting as
a riveter. Are you part
of. Can you remember
any more amusing times that happened
around the place. It's it's
a long time to it's
a long time to go back and i know
it you're
a you when you was that age. It was always
getting you know you know getting up to
addict. But i can't remember any and
he's any special. Do you remember
being around the office doing what it was
like around the office. Oh yes. Good good
. I mean i don't think i
was ever cut out the be
a no office. I was that girl
. At. You wasn't
venturous enough for me in our eyes to
look out and say i'm up on the steel.
Do you just never really place i mean
did you used to go up before you were
actually allowed to go before you were
working out there. Oh yeah you know in the
lunch you know it's
a sneak up there. And what you
do when you get up there are
a good look around make bloody sure
it was back to you back on time.
Do you remember when you were
finished up on the bridge. Oh
no it just you finished up because everything
was you know everything was working
and all that. So what did you do then what
happened to you. And we all went up to
brisbane in anticipation of the exhibition
but we were about three or four or five
years too early but we you
know was on the dole. I
think we used to get six shillings
a week a year. One week and
a day's work the next week that so
that i mean and six. But you there
were four of us living in a house you know
a good or not. Right. What about when
you came back from brisbane and all the
father had
a shop that you can think then. And i
used to helping in it you know there
in the meantime i'd be out looking for
a job every morning. But it was
no work about. You go down
and. Eat you places and that doesn't
mean you know stand outside
. It then the boss would come out and
know of it. After leaving it there for
a couple of hours. But that
is the first time i got to
you know back end of the side
without the i just botany. Working
at automatic
a world english scene which i never
certainly like. But i still managed to do
it then i went to sydney
steel merrick all. I
was i started in 1935. And you went
down to the grave. We were you
building the case and and i got
a job with the navy is
a new building at sea. Which is
quite good. If you first of all
i know that you will. It's
dock. And you were building as
a floating dock. Actually i was
attached more to dock. And
anyhow i left there to go as the
world. Ing supervisor for the vacuum
a little company and in 1960. I left there
and to get out my own as
a welding consultant.
Which was very good and
. Anyhow i left because the
firm that i was working
for they belong. You know interstate
and all that which i didn't want to go
. Anyhow after that i went to
the foreman for us. Must deal
fabricating. And i left there in 1969
and i thought well that's it. I've
got one and i work at him all
a bit after about three months
and nearly drove me mad and got
a job on the water board as you try
and clerical assistant the engineer
and i left there in 1977 i worked for mr.
Fischer. On the tension. You were
like all boilermakers very
deaf and you. Yes i got
a definite allowance. You know only a
couple of years ago and you just heard
a number dollars. But if i
went there earlier you know i
probably got more you also have
a very gruff voice do you do you attribute
that to any particular thing as far as
the all work is concerned i got a bloody
cold and i'm shiver in. It because it's
a lousy day. But i notice.
Ian ferrier also has
a very very gruff voice not unlike yours
i was wanting to do with the dust or
anything to do with welding for instance.
Well i don't know if you could be i've
never analysed it. Yeah
yeah well the end was
not so i don't know where that doesn't
leave us anywhere but to answer the back
week as well it could be could be
anything so you know there was anything
there. As far as looking
back working on the bridge.
Why do you think now fifty
years later you well it was
a an experience that i was pleased to go
through because after seeing some of the
people that i suppose that live
there because working today. It's
a bloody disgrace you think the bridge was
very well built. Oh yes yes. You know
doubt about it. It was.
You know the inspection
and the actual and it design of it.
Well everything had to be perfect.
And i don't my right that
a big perfect. What do you think about the
proposals to put more lanes on the beach
now. Well i think the fact
that of safety that it was
a build and it could easily taken because
. The fact of the safety that
that was built under it was
a greatly reduced. Now. Because i think
engineering today and it's
got it worked out that. As
i know you what can be done. I want
can't be done so with all ridges though
i know the one in melbourne. It will have
a bit of bad luck. So what about the idea
of putting extra lines on do you think it
could be done or should be done. Well you
know these days. I don't go over that.
A bit as i've got to do something. Haven't
they. I think they should build another
bridge. Because they sit and read the blood
do you think. And i mean other fifty
years before they even start it. You
worked on the doctor that you do you think
they could build another tunnel.
Yes well i know the god i
am in other parts of the world. I know the
time that it's going to take to do it
in control of that time that you would
have done i know as well. It's just out of
the question do you remember many people
who worked on the bridge other other
people. Oh well
it's hard to say it have to see their
head. And yet have to know their name and
they have to bring something up that
you know. You knew that happened
. But it is
a view as to give me names or if i want to
see somebody in the street. Now i know i
mean fairs and other senior charlie
venice journalists but i could walk past
people that i didn't know. That
a bureau wouldn't recognize it.
Well thank you very much mr.
Root spin could have usa to give
me the time. Thanks guys for that.